>>Ashleigh: I dropped out when
I was about in the ninth grade,
kind of like just to hang
out and socialize, you know,
and do drugs, party, whatever.
And I decided when I got
pregnant that I wanted
to get my life straight, have a life.
I heard about Sunset.
I came on down, and I got enrolled.
And I basically went
from being a ninth-grader
to almost being an eleventh-grader,
and that's only in one year.
>>Teacher: If he's uphill, you're
going to have positive slopes, okay?
>>Narrator: Like many
of her fellow students,
Ashleigh Scholler is making the most
of her second chance at Sunset South,
a unique Clark County high
school that caters to the needs
of some 500 students who
might otherwise drop out.
>>Come here, Haley.
>>Kay: We have a day nursery with
our school, which allows the father
and the mother to come to school
and have their child
on-campus and safely cared for.
We have kids that work
early-morning construction.
late-night at casinos.
And so the high school that goes
from 2:00 in the afternoon to 9:00
in the evening is perfect
for these kids.
>>Ashleigh: Does this have anything
to do with a negative and a positive
when you've got to find the--
>>Teacher: It sure does.
>>Kay: They don't have to
give up their education
if they need money
and they need a job.
>>How is school going?
>>It's going good.
>>Narrator: Before he enrolled at
Sunset, Joe Paterna was parking cars.
>>Joe: Then I got the
opportunity to get the valet job,
so I started working valet.
I was making pretty good
money, so I just kind of said,
"I'll get my G.E.D., and I'll just do
valet because I'm making good money."
>>Have a good night.
>>Joe: I think I can make up to 130
dollars a night on the weekends,
maybe, and it's real easy because
you don't need the education
to make the money.
>>Kay: In Las Vegas, there are a lot
of jobs that pay a lot for busboys
and valets and such at the
beginning, but as they get older,
who wants to be a 45-year-old
busboy or a 50-year-old valet?
So if they're going to
go up in management,
they need to get more
skills and more education.
>>Joseph: Without an education,
there's really not
much out there for you.
At least he'll have the education
to fall back on if this doesn't pan
out for him, or if he moves on into a
different field, it's there for him.
>>Teacher: We're going to
be doing graphing of a line.
>>Joe: It's a different environment.
The teachers are a lot
more understanding.
They help you out more.
It's a good school to come to
because they know your needs.
They know you're working, so
they really reward you for that.
Everyone's pretty motivated because
this is like your last shot here,
basically, so everyone's just trying
to get out and get the diploma.
>>Kay: Last year we
had 100 graduates,
and I think my biggest joy is
seeing someone who came hesitatingly
to our school and makes
the honor roll and says,
"Hey, I am going to graduate.
I can do it."
>>Narrator: Before the semester
ended, Ashleigh Scholler withdrew
from Sunset for personal reasons,
and Joe Paterna lost his job
when Binion's Casino was
temporarily shut down.
He is focusing on his studies
and graduated in June 2004.
>>For more information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org.